so right over here we have the recipe
for
super cake which you want to make for
your guests that are coming over for
dinner tonight
but this recipe right over here this is
for 32 people this would serve 32
folks
but you only have 16 guests coming over
so if you only have 16 guests coming
over what should be your ingredients
here how much of each of these
ingredients should you have and i
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it
all right so right now we're gonna think
about well we're gonna have a slightly
smaller super cake
smaller
super
super cake
and you might have reasoned that look if
we're going to have half as many guests
then each of the ingredients we should
just have half as much and you would be
right instead of eight eggs for a
smaller super cake you could have four
eggs instead of six cups of flour in our
smaller super cake you could have three
cups of flour instead of six cups of
sugar you could have three cups of sugar
i'm just taking half of each of these
numbers instead of two cups of butter
you could have one cup of butter instead
of six teaspoons of baking soda you
could have three teaspoons of baking
soda and last but not least instead of
two cups of water you could have one cup
of water
now this will work and this is actually
how you should adjust recipes but
there's something interesting about
what's similar about these two recipes
the recipe for the main super cake that
feeds 32 people and the recipe for the
smaller super cake and that's the notion
of ratios the ratios between ingredients
or the ratio of how much of an
ingredient you need for a given guest so
for example you can see here that for
every eight eggs you have six cups of
flour so let me write this down
so for
every
eight eggs
we have six cups of flour
we
have
six
cups
of flour which is can be expressed as a
ratio of the ratio of eggs to flour is 8
which is once again interpreted as for
every 8 eggs i have 6 cups of flour if i
said for every 6 cups of flour i have 8
eggs i would have written six
to
eight so the order here matters but here
i'm saying the ratio of eggs to flour of
eggs to cups of flour is eight to six
for every eight eggs i have six cups of
flour well what about for the smaller
cake
well here
for
for every
four eggs for every four
eggs
we have three cups of flour
we have
three
cups
of flour
so what would this ratio be
well for every four eggs
we have
three
cups of flour so the ratio of eggs to
flour is four to three
now it turns out that these are the
exact same ratio if you have eight eggs
for every six cups of flour or for every
eight eggs you have six cups of flour
that's the same thing as for every four
eggs you have three cups of flour what
you're just doing is taking each of
these numbers and you are dividing it by
two so you could say the ratio in either
case the ratio of eggs to flour let me
write this down
the ratio
of
eggs
to
two cups of flour
let me write it two
cups of flour
cups
of
flour
in either case is
is
four eggs
for every three cups of flour this is
going to be true for either recipe you
have the same ratio if you have eight
eggs here so for every four eggs you
have three cups of flour well that means
you're going to have six cups of flour
and so this is why ratios are helpful
this recipe has a different number of
eggs a different number of cups of flour
different
number of cups of sugar but the ratios
between the ingredients are the same and
so you will be able to have a cake that
tastes the same that essentially is the
same cake but just is a different size